what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
members of the Rob core what is up guys
I'm sure a lot of you guys are just like
quarter pals
what quarter miles okay so here is the
deal here's the explanation on this I
get questions all the time I want to
read Batman where do I start I want to
read Superman what do I start Wonder
Woman Justice League for whatever reason
I don't understand cyborg you know but
whatever the case may be if people are
just like I'm interested in this
character and or team and I want to know
where to start or will you make a video
on this now a lot of you guys have said
that my upload schedule seemed kind of
confusing that I was covering too many
series and it was hard to keep track and
that's true that was a legitimate
complaint we had DC we birth and then
green lantern we had only while
different Marvel and then classic
spider-man superior spider-man that kind
of thing and so I figured why I'd go
ahead and do I've always tried to hold
off from doing this since I try to
maintain some measure of expectation on
when certain videos are gonna be out but
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
basically update my video schedule we're
gonna switch things around so in the
description you will find an updated
video schedule where basically every day
has its own video style so there is a
day for the new 52 which are all the
stories that lead into DC rebirth there
is a day for classic Marvel basically
everything before Secret Wars there is a
day for all-new all-different marvel
everything after Secret Wars there is a
day for Geoff Johns Green Lantern run
it'll take us forever to finish there's
a day for indie comics and all that kind
of good stuff in a day for how to kill
superheroes everything that you need
will be in that schedule so those of you
guys who only care about classic Marvel
will only find classic Marvel on the
classic Marvel days those are the guys
who only care about DC rebirth so on and
so forth that kind of thing for all the
video styles that are listed below this
is really just kind of testing the
waters just really kind of seeing how
you guys respond to this having said
that for those of you guys who were new
to DC Comics the new 52 leads into DC
rebirth so everything labeled new 52
will be before DC rebirth now I have
playlists on Batman and stuff like that
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
these these new 52 videos and we're
gonna put them before all the DC rebirth
stuff that way you can watch the
playlist in chronological order and not
have to worry about anything I'll take
care of all the organization on this
side so all you have to do is just click
the video and watch and you don't have
to try to figure out the viewing order
or anything along those lines so the
fact remains here new 52 Batman quarter
valves it's the best Batman story there
was dare I say the best thing coming out
of DC rebirth technically
guess I guess the best thing leading
into DC rebirth there we go Scott Snyder
as the guy who was writing this story
alongside Gregor Pula they did not
originate her at least Scott Snyder did
not originate on Batman with court of
owls in fact he wrote a story before the
new 52 called Batman Black Mirror I was
not wildly partial to it but Scott
Snyder and Greta Pulos run on Batman in
the new 52 is critically acclaimed
people absolutely love it there was one
time I went to go see scott Snyder at
New York Comic Con it was right at the
end of his run on Batman in game or
something like that and the line was out
the door and around the building it was
crazy how long long it was to see him it
was one of the nuttiest things that I've
ever seen the fact remains here with
regards to quarter Valens getting into
the story proper because I'm sure a lot
of you guys are just like get to the
story man with regards to court of owls
this is cool because what it initially
shows us is just Batman being Batman
right because keep in mind this was the
introduction of a lot of people to
Batman comics I mean people knew who
Batman was he's a household name you
know he's a staple of pop culture in
general a staple of American society if
not world society and so because of that
you know people getting into this are
basically you know just kind of picking
this up with Batman just being a hell
out of people in Arkham Asylum now
really it's just kind of like a revolt
you know people have managed to make
their way out of their cells we're not
really told how explicitly and it's not
wildly relevant but the funny thing is
that in the middle of all this we end up
having the Joker joining the fray now on
the surface this presented a really
interesting scenario and the reason why
is because of the fact that the Joker is
very much a wild card in the Batman
mythos even just the DC landscape as a
whole the Joker could pop up anywhere
the Joker to show up in Metropolis the
Joker to show up in Keystone City where
you know Jay Garrick is that the aureus
Jay Garrick was at the Joker could pop
up in Central City you know he could pop
up in ko City he could pop up all over
the place that's one of the cool things
is you never know when he will appear at
the same time whenever the Joker does
show up whether he appears to a villain
or a good guy
no one knows what'll happen maybe he's
there to just lend his a for whatever
reason or maybe he's there to just kill
everyone regardless like the Joker will
show up and just implement these schemes
that make sense to no one but himself
and so with the Joker being here the
idea is that he basically starts
fighting on behalf of
and the funny thing is that the the
villain response to this is you know
well Joker's lost his mind Joker's gone
crazy
one of the roles going on here why is
Java fighting alongside Batman now this
is kind of cool because the conflict in
and of itself is just wrapped up really
fast I mean it's not designed to be
grandiose it's just designed to be hey
guys here's what Batman is about in the
new 52
he's very similar to the Batman that you
remember now one thing that I do want to
point out here is that when the new 52
first started superheroes had basically
only been around for about five years
and so the idea of Batman you know Bruce
Wayne being Batman for for a decade or
so you know for years and years and
years and years that was gone
not only that Jim Gordon was still
relatively new to Bruce Wayne and so the
trust that we were used to in the pre
new 52 continuity the trust that had
been built up between Jim Gordon and
Batman wasn't there they were
effectively starting off fresh and so
because of that Jim Gordon does trust
Batman to a degree but nowhere near the
way that he did before the new 52 he
still looks at him still kind of
believes you know well maybe Batman's a
little bit nefarious maybe Batman you
know he is a vigilante maybe he's not
necessarily on our side 100% of the time
Jim Gordon's still putting some feelings
out of feelers out there he's still
trying to get a lay of the land with
regards to balan of course he doesn't
know where's Bruce Wayne but still
trying to get a lay of the land with
regards to the Batman character now
following this we basically end up
finding out that uh you know the Joker
was essentially Dick Grayson in disguise
which is cool which is actually kind of
interesting to see Batman employing
these different forms of subterfuge
against villains and everything's like
that kind of throwing him off kilter and
and so on but the other half of this is
basically the public face that Batman
puts on the face of Bruce Wayne and this
was kind of ironic about the Batman
character we look at Batman and we say
okay look there's Bruce Wayne and
there's Batman but in truth the real
person is Batman the face that the world
sees is Bruce Wayne you know it's almost
like the line from Kill Bill you know he
was talking about a staple of superhero
mythology and Superman and Clark Kent
that kind of thing
Bruce Wayne is the alter-ego that's the
disguise that's the face that gets put
onto the world Batman is the actual
identity and that's what makes it so
cool is because Bruce Wayne is basically
Batman that's who he is
at his core Bruce Wayne is just the mass
that he puts on when he talks to the
world but the other half of this is it
shows us all the charitable works and
the kind of things that he gets into of
course it's this whole notion that for
the most part he focuses heavily on the
idea of trying to make Gotham City a
better place so it's a multi-faceted
attempt to basically make the autumn
better it's not enough to fight crime it
has to be something where he basically
improves on impoverished areas he gives
money to the kind of charities that can
do good in the city so again it's really
focusing on the idea that that Bruce
Wayne trying to save Gotham is a
two-sided coin you know one side is
beating up criminals in the middle of
the night as Batman the other side is
putting money where it can best be used
as Bruce Wayne and so far only this we
actually pick up with Harvey Bullock and
we pick up where that man with a burning
sign that says you know Bruce Wayne will
die tomorrow that kind of thing but the
other half of this is that there's also
a guy who's basically been pinned to the
wall and been injected with a ton of
knives now this is where the court of
owls begins to come into play and this
is one of the reasons why the court of
owls was so cool is because we end up
finding out there is a lot going on in
the realm of Gotham that Batman just
doesn't know about what is up happening
is you basically pick up with you know
Batman and Jim go I'm sorry Jim Gordon
and guy that does autopsies and stuff
the name escapes me but you know we pick
up with them kind of analyzing this body
and then of course Batman shows up and
Batman Begins going through and of
course what we end up finding is that in
one of his teeth is a filling and inside
this filling is an owl symbol and the
whole notion is that this ties into an
old rhyme that Bruce Wayne members as a
kid about the court of owls
Anasuya the way the rhyme went he was
one of those things where it was like
the court of owls is this a nefarious
group that exists under ground behind
Gotham City and if you talk bad about
them they'll come and find you one of
the things that this really seemed to
hit home at is that it was a children's
run it was designed to basically keep
kids in check if you don't do your
homework the court of owls will come and
get you if you treat people bad the
court of owls will come and get you
they'll send the Talon and the Talon
will take you away you know what you
never know where the court of owls is
that it was really really spooky when I
first read this because the idea of
Bruce Wayne not knowing about this
nefarious organization that exists
within the realm of Gotham City is just
kind of mind-blowing right like Bruce
Wayne knows Gotham in and out he knows
it like the back of his hand and that's
the beauty of court of owls is it takes
the idea that Batman is Gotham and
philippson on his head and says maybe
there are things about Gotham
the Batman doesn't know about that
Batman's totally unaware of now of
course what this does is it says look
you know it kind of creates this
timetable of sorts where Batman has 12
hours before you know whatever it is it
happens leads to his death but this
actually comes I guess really kind of
brings us to a meeting between Lincoln
March and Bruce Wayne now Lincoln March
is a guy who's basically running for
mayor he's running for a major position
and Gotham City proper but the way that
the kind of society puts on here and
really the way he engaged in the Bruce
Wayne is that they are very very much
similar and that's kind of the cool
thing here is Bruce Wayne wants to put
money where Bohr can best be used
Lincoln March can make that happen
Lincoln March can basically say hey look
here are the areas where money can best
be spent in the city I've combed over
you know all the different areas that
are that are basically struggling the
areas that are a little more abject and
I guess telling an abject poverty than
anything else money can be put in these
different places and it can be used the
most effectively the problem with this
is that in the middle of this whole
discussion we basically end up running
directly into the talent now the talent
is effectively the long arm of the court
about you know he is the guy the court
of owls Sims out to take out those
individuals who they've deemed to be a
threat which is to say those individuals
that they want to have killed now the
funny thing about this is that Scott
Snyder does a really good job of sort of
going through and teasing these
different concepts teasing these
different ideas of how far back the
court of owls goes for example the Talon
makes the statement how I love killing
Wayne's and so the question that was
being presented here when this story
first dropped is is the court of owls
responsible for the death of Thomas and
Martha Wayne now it creates kind of a
funny situation because historically
speaking in DC Comics you know really
and almost every iteration of Batman's
origin Thomas and Martha Wayne were
basically killed by Joe Chill there were
times where the motivations of Geo Chill
were changed but he was always the guy
that killed him now more often than not
it was just Joe Chill was a guy who was
down on his luck and he was struggling
and he came across them and there were
people who who looked at as you know
looked as though they came from wealth
they had you know jewelry so on and so
forth
and in the midst of the situation and
the heat of the moment he pulled the
trigger and killed them both there's
also been other things where it's like
you know Joe Chill was a monster and so
on and so forth but the fact remains
here that Joe Chill murdering the
parents of Bruce Wayne is a core aspect
of his of his whole story this is one of
the things that really kind of kind of
intrigued people it was the question of
is that the case is this really what's
going on now of course in the middle of
this fight between between Batman and
and the talent one of the other things
that Scott Steiner really hits at is the
idea of how well Batman knows Gotham
City for example in this whole rooftop
fight we end up having a scenario where
they both fall out of the building and
the result is that you know Bruce Wayne
basically says I know this city like the
back of my hand
I know where the gargoyles are
positioned around this building and so I
know where to jump out I know where to
go I know how to make sure that I can
survive by grabbing on to something the
Talon doesn't know that and so where you
know Bruce Wayne jumps onto this
gargoyle the Talon presumably falls to
his death only for us to find out that
the Talon is very much alive which is
revealed to us when he basically kills
the paramedic so again what we end up
doing is we basically follow this this
path that Bruce Wayne's going on in
order to learn everything that's going
on let's do the half of this Scott
Snyder spent a lot of time focusing on
the notion of Bruce Wayne very much
being a detective Bruce Wayne very much
being a guy who doesn't just go out and
beat people up and like you know punch
around criminals and stuff like that he
uses his mind as much as he uses his
fists and his feet and so it's kind of
cool because it's Scott Snyder basically
reaffirming what existing Batman fans
already know and in forming new Batman
fans that Bruce Wayne is a multi-faceted
guy he's a jack of all trades and a
master of all trades he knows how to do
it all this eventually leads into Bruce
Wayne meeting directly with Lincoln
March of course Lincoln March having
been injured in the assault but Lincoln
basically kind of issues out this
warning to Bruce Wayne this says look
man you have to watch out for the court
of owls now one major theme here is that
Bruce was like there is no court of owls
I would know if the court of owls exists
I'm Batman
if the court of owls is there I know
about it I know Gotham better than
anybody and if the court of owls was was
real whoo I guarantee they would have
been arrested or I'd be keeping tabs on
them or something like that
now what Lincoln does is he gives us
like this really really spooky situation
you know rebate he's basically kind of
told you know look I was warned by the
court of owls and what they did is they
basically put like a little owl nest
with some bones in my home when I came
home I found that there and that's
really what the court of owls does they
issue these little warnings you know and
it's just kind of like a hey back off
like we're watching you whatever it is
you're doing we don't like now Scott
Snyder also just kind of goes to this
idea that it's like a big thing right I
mean the court of owls is not gonna give
you you know a warning because you went
to the wrong grocery store what it is is
someone like Lincoln March that wants to
issue a whole bunch of change around the
city of Gotham is working against the
interests of the court of owls so as
basically Scott Snyder dropping these
clues and essentially telling us that
with the court of owls that they are
very much rooted in the history of
Gotham indicating here that the court of
owls are basically composed of some of
Gotham's wealthy
we know what goes on with them now but
at the time of this story we didn't know
that but again this all really follows
the idea of Batman investigating further
of Batman going through and trying to
figure everything out
now just by virtue of his own
investigations and his own resources
what Batman ends up doing is basically
going to all these different buildings
that are funded by the Allan Wayne trust
for young architects in Gotham City
basically those individuals that are
that are being given charity money for
the purpose of improving Gotham City's
skyline and every time he goes to the
13th floor he ends up finding this small
little place where evidence of the court
of owls exists and all of them seem to
be locations of where the Talon resides
now the reason why this is kind of
important is because scott snyder gives
us these really kind of spooky but
really cool instances of how smart
batman is one of the things that he says
is that cities are by definition very
superstitious places people you know
keep all kinds of superstitions you know
they throw salt over their shoulder and
different things like that it's not
something that happens all the time but
there are people who are there Allan
Wayne was a very superstitious member of
the Wayne family and the result was that
throughout his own life he believed the
number thirteen was unlucky as did a
multitude of people and so back in the
early days of when cities are being
built when people were still very
superstitious when they built buildings
they would skip over the 13th floor he
would just go from 12 to 14 and the
result is that you would keep this
little section of the building where the
13th floor would normally be and that
would basically house the bad luck and
so in the mind of Bruce Wayne if the
court of owls exists that would most
likely be where they would reside or
where evidence would belong and as he
goes through every single one of these
buildings that's exactly what he finds
he basically finds stockpiles of arms
and armament he finds all kinds of
things that belong to the court of owls
and documentation
that proves their existence now in the
mind of Batman he's still not 100%
onboard even after he goes into one of
the buildings and he basically acted it
activates a trip device that ends up
resulting in his you know in a massive
explosion that almost causes him to die
he still has a hard time believing it to
be true and the reason why is because of
the fact that in a conversation that he
has with Dick Grayson we end up learning
that following the death of Bruce
Wayne's parents that he believed the
court of owls was behind it as a child
he had heard the nursery rhyme he'd
heard the stories heard the tales and
thought the court of owls may have been
the ones who had led all this and so
what he ended up doing was going around
and doing all this different research
now again this is Snyder showing us how
early Batman's detective skills were
honed and used and so it really showed
us that the death of his parents changed
him in a fundamental way but he started
going through and looking at all these
different clues signs of owls and
different things like that
all of which basically led him back to a
place called Harbor house now Harbor
house was a former meeting ground for
Gotham's social elite now it had long
since been abandoned but it had
different signs of owls and so on and so
forth and so where Bruce Wayne as a
child had basically looked around and
believed the idea that if the court of
owls was real and they basically you
know not really worship owls so much is
strongly associated themselves with owls
in places that would have a lot of
decoration regarding house would likely
be their place of business now this was
also rooted in the idea that his parents
because they were part of Gotham's
social elite and had associated with
Gotham's wealthiest individuals that
those wealthy people were probably part
of the court of owls and so again this
all sort of fed into this idea that the
court of owls were the ones behind his
parents murder the problem with this is
that once he gets to where he believed
that they would be meeting or where they
would be located ultimately he finds
absolutely nothing he simply finds that
there's nothing there now in addition to
this Batman had actually exhumed Allan
Wayne's body and just kind of analyzed
his bones and number things like that
again all that basically went into him
kind of tracing back the roots or the
existence of the court of owls now the
reason why was because of the fact that
Allan Wayne himself had died under
mysterious circumstances he was just
found in a sewer one day and so the
result was he was identified by his
dental records what it ended up doing is
it basically set in motion this idea
that if Allan Wayne had just suddenly
vanished under mysterious circumstances
if people are being killed
you know without any real indication of
why if the court of owls does exist then
the sewer may very well hold the answer
now again
Snyder's just kind of connecting these
dots and he's is kind of bringing them
together in a natural progression which
does make sense but what Batman does is
he says look on the bones of Allan Wayne
was this kind of weird material kind of
like a white powder of sorts which
doesn't make any sense because the fact
that there's no materials in the sewers
of Gotham that has that same kind of
substance attached to them and so the
indication seems to be that Allan Wayne
was held in a place that was within
Gotham but not visible to the normal
human eye meaning it was very much
hidden away and so of course where he's
in the middle of this whole
investigation he's ultimately a
surprised and subdued by the talent
after which he wakes up in the labyrinth
of the court of owls now this is one of
the coolest moments and the reason why
is because this shows us how easy it is
for the court of owls to break the
Batman but it also shows us how far back
they go and how extensively they've
reached out and assassinated various
people now the court of owls as they're
shown to us are basically people who
were these owl masters these really
really cool masts over their faces when
this story came out people were just
cosplaying as court of owls
that's all you saw at Comic Cons were
just like court avowal masks and it was
so cool to see but the whole idea is
that as he goes through this labyrinth
he's effectively losing his mind he's
losing his sanity now this appears to be
a combination of isolation and just
constant exposure to light the fact that
he can't sleep I mean he's sleep
deprived
he's almost dehydrated hungry I mean
it's just all these different things to
sort of come together for the purpose of
pushing Batman to the absolute brink of
his sanity and this really comes to play
when he hallucinates his parents who in
turn basically begin kind of you know
rema t realizing and dissolving and then
turning into bats and so again it gets
really really crazy but in the middle of
all this you know when he's basically
just kind of losing his mind starting to
go insane
he's attacked from behind by the Talon
and at least presumably killed now again
this is really kind of Snyder just
wrapping things up quick fast and in a
hurry but again this is really
significant here because very rarely
have we ever seen Batman out of control
which is to say not in control of his
surroundings or not calm or not
collected that's a hallmark of Batman
you know no matter
all bad it gets no matter how terrible
things are Batman is the one guy that
always stays saying he's always the one
guy that's like there's got to be a way
to think ourselves out of this there's
got to be a way for us to initiate a
plan or to do something you know he's
the backbone of really the Justice
League in a lot of ways I mean you've
got Superman who's just pure strength
you have Wonder Woman whose strength and
strategy you have Green Lantern I mean
you know all these different characters
Batman is the backbone of the Justice
League in terms of his intelligence his
resources his ability to basically think
himself and others out of almost any
situation to have a plan for virtually
any scenario to see him broken to see
him pushed to the brink of almost
complete and total insanity is crazy and
it was it was absolutely nuts to read
this at the time that it came out it was
like good god like Batman's lost his
mind and so it's really cool but of
course what we end up having here is the
scenario of the court of owls playing
out in the sense that when a person
basically goes against the wishes of the
court when they're issued a warning and
they ignore it and they're brought to
the labyrinth they're basically kind of
pushed to the point of insanity and
they're told you're going to lose your
mind and then we're effectively going to
kill you and basically there's kind of
sacrifice now the judgment is made by
the court themselves and the town is the
one who carries it out and so with the
town being the agent of Batman the
talent basically just kind of beats him
up fights him you know with the
intention of killing him and then Batman
more or less just kind of falls prey to
his darker side now the way this is
shown by Greg Capullo and the way that
it's written by Scott Snyder is a
perfect example of how a metaphor meets
reality in the sense that Batman falling
into his darker side Batman basically
losing his human nature in becoming a
dark version of himself is manifested in
terms of how he looks now he doesn't
actually look this way he has a grown
teeth or anything like that it's just
kind of here to show us this is where
Batman is now you know he's he's
basically dark he's brooding he's you
know not really evil he's just kind of
lost his humanity even if only for a
temporary amount of time and so he's
very very feral and so in this moment of
desperation in this moment of panic he
basically begins going against the Talon
and fighting him off as best he can but
the other half of this is that Scott
Snyder very much focuses on the
intelligence of Batman which is to say
that once he recovered from this
temporary insanity
once he subdues the talent he also just
kind of goes back to being as
intelligent as he is and one of the
things that he had done was
that when he was going through the
labyrinth he had come across an old
camera now with regards to the court
because of the fact that they're so
rooted in antiquity because they used so
many antique things the camera that they
use dates all the way back to the days
when they basically use magnesium in
order to create flashes and cameras now
in addition to being able to use
magnesium there was also flash powder
which is a combination of potassium
chlorate and magnesium and so what
Batman basically realized was that
inside this camera was essentially a
filament plate that was made of
potassium chlorate and that because of
the fact that he's so familiar with
Gotham he was in turn able to realize
that the statue was basically white
marble instead of construction marble
which makes it easier makes it softer
and more prone to destruction and so by
putting these two together
he basically realizes he has a way out
he ignites the potassium chlorate blows
up the fountain and escapes down through
a hole and that's the coolest thing here
is it shows us how smart Batman is how
capable he is now again this is also
basically Scott Snyder's saying that
this whole story about showing how
Batman didn't know the court of owls
existed really kind of hits home to the
idea that yes he's not as familiar with
Gotham City as he would like but he
still knows it better than almost
anybody not only that it also shows us
the arrogance and the hubris of the
court of owls and so that's kind of
Scott Steiner bringing things back to
roots saying hey look here's this
clandestine organization that Batman
never really seemed to know about they
seemed almost you know supernatural in
terms of their form and function but at
the end of the day they're people
they're bad guys they're arrogant they
have hubris they believe that nobody can
defeat them they've existed so long from
the shadows that they can't envision a
scenario where they could not only be
discovered but brought down so again
it's really just kind of hitting home to
the nature kind of wrap everything back
around to the core of the Batman comics
okay so getting into new 52 Batman well
technically is called city of owls but
it's really called like night of the
owls I think really in terms of how I
how I sort of look at it really it's
like this great big huge like 12 issues
story arc more or less that might even
be closer to 13 um but it's really just
kind of called the court of owls
storyline but it's really kind of split
into two things but the fact remains
that this video right here will
basically wrap up the court in the
traditional sense but the cool thing
about this is that during the whole you
know revelation of the court of owls
Bruce Wayne had actually come across and
realized the basis behind de Grayson now
this was really a little bit of a
controversial thing and the reason for
this is because of the fact that dick
Grayson's history was pretty standard in
the sense that he was very much like
Bruce Wayne Bruce Wayne witnesses mother
and father being killed by a guy in an
alleyway and it inspired him to become
Batman Dick Grayson was much the same
way he was part of a trapeze group
called the flying Grayson's his parents
were killed and the result was that he
was taken in by Bruce Wayne and
eventually desired revenge allowing him
to go forward as Bruce Wayne's training
the difference here is that as Robin
Dick Grayson was like this incorruptible
character where Bruce was dark and Bruce
was brooding Dick Grayson always looked
to the light always looked to the better
idea of how things could be and for the
most part that was maintained to a
degree you know with regards to the new
52 you he was still relatively similar
to that now of course DC started messing
around with his carrots a little bit
making him a secret agent you know
bringing in agencies like Spiral and
different things like that and that
received kind of a lukewarm reception
some like did some hated it but with the
really with the Nightwing tie-in to the
court of owls a court of owls event what
we ended up finding out was that were
traditionally Hayley Circus was just a
circus in actuality they were
functioning with a pact that went
alongside the court of owls and what
would happen is Hayley's circus would
basically present us some of their most
outstanding you know acrobats or their
outstanding trapeze and those trapeze
would be used by the court of owls for
the purpose of eventually becoming the
talent now what despit is it expanded on
the talent mythos and it actually
introduced a guy by the name of William
Cobb now of course BC try to expand on
the role of the talent it didn't really
catch on and nobody really cared that
much in truth it's kind of viewed him as
a henchman and that was really about it
but the idea was that William Cobb was
one of a long line of men who had played
the role of the talent just like the
court of owls the modern day you know
iteration of the court of owls was one
of a long line of groups who have been
part of the court of owls and the idea
here was that the court would basically
poison the the blood stream of
individuals with something called
electrum I believe it was and what would
essentially happen is it would permeate
their cells so that when the time came
when that person died for whatever
reason whether it was old age whether
they were killed prematurely whatever
the case may be the court of owls would
take their body they would basically
bring them back to life with something
called Dionysian and then in turn they
would become a talent and that was the
intention for degree
that Dick Grayson was basically selected
by the court to be their newest talent
once William Cobb served his purpose or
was presumably dead or whatever the case
may be and so what would happen is Dick
Grayson would basically live out his
life you know and whatever means he
ended up living it out in and then maybe
he'll die in a car wreck or maybe he'll
die of old age or whatever the case may
be but when that happens he would be
brought in by the court of owls and then
they would basically make him into a
Talon and so he would go forward
basically as one of their assassins and
of course it wouldn't really be old age
that would kill him I mean you know they
would have him killed probably in the
prime of his life just to make sure that
you didn't have like a 90 year old Dick
Grayson running around trying to
assassinate people but the fact remains
here he had unwittingly been selected as
an assassin and so again that was kind
of a huge revelation here and so what
that did is it really kind of like
double the efforts of Bruce Wayne right
because now you know Scott Snyder and
NDC it basically established that it
wasn't just a matter of oh I need to
stop the stop that court of owls now it
was the court of owls aren't just trying
to seize control of Gotham City they're
turning the lives of people upside down
and so again it really kind of doubled
the efforts of Bruce Wayne in his desire
to take them out now of course again
when we end the last video of the court
of owls we had basically picked up with
the idea that the the court themselves
had basically gone through and said okay
look you know if Batman is going to work
against us and if we cannot take control
of the city by going in and influencing
candidates and operating behind the
scenes then we'll take the city by force
and so what they did is they basically
unleashed all of their talents and symp
them all throughout Gotham City now this
is when the comic books of like
Nightwing and I think that girl had been
published at the time and Detective
Comics and a few others basically came
in and covered a lot of the nine of our
stuff um all that really happened with
the court with regards to those world
high ons it's what we haven't really
covered them it's because we're focusing
mostly on Batman all that it really
happened with those tie-ins is the bat
family had discovered that the court
looked to take out certain individuals
who were influential in Gotham but stood
against the court or worked against the
the goals and desires of the court
whether those people knew about the
court or not all the bat family really
did everybody outside of Batman for the
most part all they really did was run
around and save those people who were on
the hit list that was really it I mean
that was really the extent of it it was
interesting but is by no means required
reading for you know for the whole court
of owls story with up with Batman but
with regards to Bruce himself the court
actually goes through and really the
talons just kind of descend on Wayne
Manor and immediately attack him now
this is kind of the important thing here
because what is up happening and really
what we saw with regards to you know the
the first court of owls video that we
did and so the court themselves knew
that Bruce Wayne was Batman and that was
really one of the big revelations
because in the realm of DC on the DC
Universe one of the most closely guarded
secrets is the identity of Batman the
identity of Superman the identity of
Wonder Woman that's one of the most
closely guarded things they try not to
let the world know about that just
because of the fact that if people knew
that Clark Kent was Superman then Lois
Lane would be in jeopardy and you know
Perry would be in jeopardy and and so on
and so forth you know Jimmy Olsen and so
on Bruce Wayne is the exact same way if
they knew that Bruce Wayne was Batman
you could just literally tear down
everything that Bruce Wayne's built you
could launch a multitude of campaigns
against him now this one is a little
more tangible and it's really kind of
Scott Snyder bringing in the other half
of Batman's storytelling and that's why
it's so cool
because historically speaking whenever
we read Batman stories we expect to see
a blend of detective work and then
fighting I mean that's really one of the
things we like to see is Batman just
beating people up it's one of the
coolest things about his storytelling
you know how ruthless he can be
sometimes you know push the person to
the point where they genuinely believe
they're gonna die but of course we know
Batman is not actually gonna kill him
with regards to this kid but here the
talons this sitting on Wayne Manor
proper is really just for the purpose of
taking out Bruce Wayne so of course what
he ends up doing is dawning this massive
you know he'll bat suit more or less and
just taking it to town on these towns I
mean really just kind of wrecking
through every last one of them because
in truth despite the fact that these
guys are relatively Undead despite the
fact that these guys you know are pretty
formidable in the end they're not really
able to take out Bruce Wayne now of
course the reason why is because of the
fact that Batman realizes that these
talents are able to run around and
they're able to do their own thing
because they're not frozen basically
extremely cold temperatures is the tool
that's used by the court to keep the
talents and stasis more or less and so
Batman's realization you know of this
information is to essentially freeze all
these guys up to basically you know use
a multitude of different resources today
Saline stasis again by using very cold
temperatures and so of course this in
conjunction with unleashing his bats on
you know the
as members of the town you know really
kind of wraps things up pretty fast and
so of course once the temperature drops
low enough all these guys more or less
just kind of freeze and go back into
stasis again and that's really the end
of them and so what it does is it allows
Batman to turn his attention to the most
logical target of the court themselves
Lincoln March now here was the kind of
cool thing about these tie-ins the way
the tie-ins took place is they all
happened basically in a time frame which
means it like at 7 o'clock this happens
a Nightwing ad you know eight o'clock
this happens in Detective Comics you
know at nine o'clock this happens in
Batgirl the problem with this is that
you would literally have to break the
comics down page by page in order to
cover it in true chronological order
otherwise you end up reading Nightwing
and then halfway through Nightwing you
have to stop and then read detective
comics and then like a quarter of the
way through detective comics you have to
stop and jump to Batgirl like it gets
really kind of weird the way it all
comes together and it really kind of
threw things off it was cool if you're
gonna symbol it that way it makes it for
a really really interesting and cohesive
story but in terms of what we're trying
to do here it would confuse the hell out
of you guys so so we're not gonna do
that we're really not gonna do a
play-by-play like and then we switch
over to Nightwing at 7:32 p.m. like
we're not we're not gonna we're not
gonna do that instead Batman of course
travels to go see Lincoln March now
again in the last video we had covered
this and we had basically said that
Lincoln shared an identity shared an
affinity for Batman in terms of how it
is they viewed Gotham City and a lot of
this revelation came at the top of Wayne
Tower
you know the building that was being
constructed by Bruce Wayne that was
basically going to be this beacon of
hope for the city of Gotham and a beacon
to the world saying that Gotham is a
desirable place to live and it was a
really cool exchange between the two of
them because Lincoln March had told this
very interesting story to Bruce Wayne
about how Lincoln's mother had died and
the last thing that he had of her
possession was basically this Miss
shapen heart-shaped pendant and it was
kind of cool to see this you know this
exchange between the two of them because
of the fact that it was a very human
moment for both it was basically both
with him realizing that they had the
same goals and they had the same
ambitions at heart the problem with this
was that as Lincoln March had explained
he was directly working against the
court of owls because of the fact that
the court had basically warned link and
stray away from the path that you're on
move away from this road that you're on
because you're conflicting our interests
and we will kill you if you don't and so
again because of this with Lincoln March
effectively on his deathbed it's almost
like he's trying to get revenge by
the name of the members of the court of
owls directly to Bruce Wayne himself and
so what we do is we transition to a
group basically a family that are called
the powers family and this is really
interesting because it's basically
composed of Joseph and his wife Maria
and the reason why this is important is
because it shows us that when it comes
to wealthy individuals Bruce Wayne is
not the only game in town now for the
most part we always kind of figured that
was the case right I mean we always kind
of figured that Bruce Wayne wasn't like
the only rich guy in Gotham but there
wasn't a whole lot of expansion in terms
of the really wealthy in Gotham as far
as normal people go we would see them
from time to time but more often than
not it would be like two-face has a ton
of money and he's doing nefarious things
who would be like penguin has a ton of
money and he's running a criminal empire
something along those lines and here's
how he runs into Batman this time that
was really yet that was really these the
only con find there when it came to
Scott Snyder expanding on the Batman
mythos it wasn't just about creating a
new group in Gotham City or at least
introducing a group in Gotham City that
Batman didn't know about that had been
operating for hundreds of years it was
bolstering that it was basically
grabbing other members of Gotham's elite
and sank what if some of Gotham's you
know wealthiest people out there weren't
working against Gotham proper and so
again it's kind of a cool scenario
because what it tells us is that where
Batman operates from the shadows
bringing down criminals there are
individuals who operate from the shadows
to conquer Gotham and that was really
what was going on with the court of owls
the court of owls wouldn't necessarily
intervene by you know sitting an army
and to Gotham City like they did with
nine of the Owls instead they would
influence politicians they would pay off
judges they would do different things
either that or they would snatch them up
and they were dragged into the labyrinth
and say you can spend the rest of your
days in this place until you go crazy
and basically you know kill yourself or
you can do what we tell you to do and
the alternative is to basically just
walk rank-and-file that's exactly what
they would do so the court of owls
functioned in a lot of different ways
but of course with Bruce Wayne being
given the names of these individuals by
Lincoln March this highlights a very
important part of the story what this
seems to indicate from Scott Snyder is
that Batman never would have realized
who they were on their own they were too
well hidden
you know Joseph and Maria powers were
just too well hidden they were too far
hands-off nobody would have known who
they were or that they were even
involved in the court of Alice now Allah
the reason why this was the case was
simply because of the fact that the
powers family lived in more or less a
penthouse in a building that nobody
could gain access to unless you were
personally invited that place was a
fortress the press was not allowed in
there the general public was not allowed
in there there's no indication that
Bruce Wayne ever saw the inside of that
they were very reclusive very shut off
now the indication of the question that
we would kind of have to ask here is
well then wouldn't that make them the
most logical people to be the court of
owls if they were so reclusive only the
first ones that Bruce Wayne would think
of yes and no because you all have the
thing from himself Bruce Wayne's very
reclusive Bruce Wayne hides out in Wayne
Manor almost all day long now for him
it's because he's Batman and because
he's fighting against crime different
things like that but no one knows what
goes on behind closed doors what seems
to be going on here is that when it
comes to the wealthy elite in Gotham its
hey you leave me alone I leave you alone
and we'll disco lit a day that really
seems to be what's happening here and so
of course with Batman tracing down the
location of the court of owls after
essentially kind of interrogating Maria
powers what is up happening here as
Alfred of course basically says hey look
she's calling her husband your plan to
basically trace the location of her
husband worked the problem is that his
phone is in a blocked out area so I can
only give you a few blocks but I can't
tell you exactly where it's located at
but this is when Scott Snyder is running
comes full circle when it's when his
whole story comes back to full circle
again and the reason why is because in
the last video we had talked about how
after the death of Bruce Wayne's parents
he had investigated the court of owls
believing that the court were the ones
that were responsible for his parents
death that a set of killing his parents
directly they hired some you know some
most low-level guy named Joe Chill to
have his parents killed and then just
make it look like a crime of desperation
when in reality you know Bruce Wayne
believed the court of owls were the ones
who pulled it off what descends up
telling us is that where Bruce Wayne
originally went to harbor house
believing the court of owls operated out
of there and found nothing the truth is
that he was right the entire time he was
right where he doubted himself where he
said no no I went there and I poked
around all the clues led to this place
being the court of owls I guess that was
wrong this is Scott Snyder saying here's
how smart Bruce Wayne is he's always
been this smart he follows the clues he
listens to logic he listens to reason
and all the clues and all the signs
indicated that the court of owls
operated out of Harbor house now this is
kind of cool because this is basically a
scenario where it essentially
scenes by the court of owls themselves
are not keeping their tracks as clean as
they thought they would or maybe they
were relying on the intelligence of
adults who would consider some things to
be nonsensical and ignore them when in
reality that nonsensical thing is an
important clue to point to the location
of the court themselves now of course
when Bruce gets to the court proper he
basically finds that they're all dead I
mean every last one of them had them
dead you know they essentially drank
some kind of a substance and ended up
killing them all now of course this
seems to be like a ritualistic suicide
of sorts that they realized or at least
you know as Alfred explains it to Bruce
Wayne that Batman had basically taken
the city back you know Batman now knew
about the court of owls and the court
themselves realized it was only a matter
of time before he brought them all down
and so they essentially just kind of
killed themselves so they wouldn't have
to wait for any measure of you know of a
trial you know being arrested or
anything along those lines and so again
the great thing about this is that Scott
Steiner gives every indication that this
is where the story is he gives every
indication that this is where it all
stops but it doesn't and that's why I
love this run so much because Binney
takes everything that we've seen so far
and flips it on its head and that's the
coolest thing the reason why is because
of the fact that Bruce Wayne is supposed
to have a meeting later on today and of
course Alfred is talking to him about
the meeting what it's supposed to be
scheduled mean needs to get ready and so
on and so forth but having a
conversation looking at a picture of
Thomas and Martha Wayne Batman takes off
and it's the coolest thing in the world
and the reason why is because he travels
to the morgue of where Lincoln March is
supposed to be and simply finds a note
that says follow me down the rabbit hole
now this is a universal sign in
literature ever since Alice in
Wonderland was written you know by lewis
carroll alice from wonderland
tumbling down the rabbit hole with
absolutely no idea what's your fine
below has been a literary metaphor for
the idea of walking down a path with no
idea what's there with the old basically
walking down a tunnel with a blindfold
on and it's really Scott's letter saying
that Batman is just following a trail of
breadcrumbs with no idea what's at the
other end but what we end up doing is
giving this little bit of an explanation
about a place called the Willow Wood
home for children now to be honest this
is creepy and it's one of the creepiest
things that I've seen so far it's almost
like the like Waverly Hills Sanatorium
or Santana whatever it is have you never
had a chance look it up it's this creepy
place in Louisville Kentucky and a buddy
of mine we're actually going to spend us
spend the night there on Halloween one
night
we decided not to because we kind of
figured that that's the place that you
go to when you accidentally stumble into
a portal that leads you like to another
dimension
that's basically hell like we're not
going we're not even messing with that
ghosts and monsters and stuff like that
not at all but this is actually uh this
is this is really kind of creepy here
and the reason why is because of the
fact that what we're told is that the
woodford home for children was basically
this place where kids with mental
disorders were taken but what we're
shown here are like like blood prints
and different things like that and as is
explained to us there was basically a
sinkhole that swallowed up the orderlies
quarters and what ended up happening
here is that because of the fact that
this place was so far removed from
Gotham City proper and because of the
fact that nobody ever checked on any of
the children here that when somebody
finally did come stumbling along they
basically found all the orderlies dead
and the kids just either starving to
death that you know or sturer dying of
dehydration walking around naked
absolutely disheveled you know and
living in their own filth and squalor I
mean it's a really really sad set of
circumstances but what this is designed
to do is feed into the sad nature of
Gotham City in a sense the Gotham is
looked at by a lot of people as a broken
City I mean it's broken and it's beyond
hope beyond redemption and should be
allowed to die just the traditional you
know line though the whole plot that we
saw from Batman Begins you know Gotham
City is a laboring beast gasping for
breath let the damn thing die but of
course we know the Batman simply won't
let that happen and the idea is to
always try to breathe new life into it
and so again this really kind of hits
home at the nature of all that now of
course what we end up finding out is
that link in March as he had basically
you know kind of taunted Batman to come
to this location begins talking to him
about how you know who he really is what
he's really about and what we end up
finding out here is that it was Lincoln
March who basically led to the deaths of
all the members of the court of owls you
know he had simply poisoned all of their
drinks while they were in their meeting
they all died at the same time Bruce
Wayne basically recalls their you know
really kind of brings the reason up in
terms of why he took off in the first
place and the reason why was because of
the story that Lincoln March had given
Bruce Wayne in Wayne you know in the
Wayne Tower when Lincoln marcha talked
about how his mother had died and left
him you know this miss shape and heart
pendant and that kind of thing and Bruce
Wayne remembered that that was the exact
same pendant that Martha Wayne was
wearing in that picture and so the
implication seemed to be here that
Lincoln March was a false name that he
was basically grabbing little
and hints from the life of Bruce Wayne
and rolling them in to a cohesive story
now what Lincoln March does here is he
basically presents the scenario that he
himself is Bruce Wayne's brother the
reason being because of the fact that
while he does have that mist shape and
heart pendant those pendants are only
given to people who are from you are
basically children that live within the
school for homes and so Lincoln marches
essentially saying here that Martha
Wayne is his mother and he's basically
the brother that Bruce Wayne never knew
about now one of the crazy things about
this is that for a lot of people the
ending of this story seemed to be an
instance where Scott Snyder kind of
wrote himself into a corner and didn't
quite know how to get out again but the
great thing about this and really one of
the reasons why I loved this is because
of the fact that it's designed to kind
of ask all these what-if questions about
Bruce Wayne remember the entirety of the
court of owls is designed for the
purpose of bringing in the possibility
that Bruce Wayne does not know as much
about Gotham as he thought he did and he
claims to know the streets inside and
out he claims to know the buildings
inside and out he claims to know the
people inside and out but he didn't know
the powers and other other members of
Gotham's wealthiest the court of owls he
didn't know the court of owls was there
this is another instance where Scott
Snyder's basically hitting home with the
idea that maybe this guy Lincoln March
is actually Thomas Wayne jr. maybe he is
the legitimate son of Thomas and Martha
Wayne and Bruce just never knew about it
the entire time now again from here this
really just kinda descends down into
into an exercise in traditional comic
book battling in the sense that you
basically just kind of have verse Wayne
funny against a Thomas Wayne junior and
that's really about it now of course the
conflict leads directly to Wayne tower
proper and the whole idea here of
Lincoln March is to essentially I guess
of Thomas Wayne this to basically bring
the tower down around Bruce and the
reason why is because this fits in to
the entirety of the narrative as it's
given to us by you know Thomas Wayne
what he basically says here at least
what both he says and what Bruce Wayne
deduces is that Thomas Wayne was
presumably left within this you know
that home for children by the Wayne's to
keep him hidden away from the world the
result was that they had Bruce Wayne
himself
and Bruce Wayne became the rightful heir
of the Wayne family while this was going
on because of the fact that Thomas was
basically abandoned and left behind he
adopted by the court of owls and then
brought in and raised by the court and
so the idea was that he basically showed
up as Gotham City's Savior when in
reality he was just a puppet of the
court of owls and so what ended up
happening here is that when he was
presumably killed by one of the talons
when Bruce Wayne stumbled in and Thomas
Wayne operating his Lincoln marched gave
Bruce Wayne the names of the members of
the court in truth he had actually
ingested that's very serum though the
talons use in order to keep them alive
and then more or less kind of
resurrected himself so to speak and so
the idea here was that if he was going
to basically replace Bruce Wayne he was
going to kill off Bruce Wayne and carry
on the memory of Bruce by operating as
the city's mayor you know or one of his
most contributing members that he's
going to do exactly that
by killing Bruce Wayne and then
effectively taking this place all Bruce
Wayne you know Bruce Wayne passed away
but I'm his brother Thomas Wayne jr.
here's the documentation to prove it
someone is so forth now of course Bruce
basically uses the hubris of Thomas
Wayne when Thomas Wayne begins
detonating the various bombs of these
planet in Wayne tower to bring it all
down Bruce Wayne manages to make his
escape and so what Scott Snyder does is
he leaves everything ambiguous he leaves
it with the idea that Thomas Wayne jr.
basically survived now we know that by
way of the story Batman eternal which
I'm not really sure if we're gonna cover
that or not but we know that Thomas
Wayne survived and he ends up coming
back what Scott Snyder did with him
there was kind of interesting but I
wouldn't say nearly as prevalent as his
role here in the court of owls storyline
but of course in the midst of all this
you know Batman's basically visited that
kind of thing and the crazy thing about
this is that the conversation between
the two of them indicates that Bruce
actually believes that Thomas Wayne jr.
might really exist now of course he goes
through the paperwork and begins looking
at the history of the Wayne's of Thomas
and Martha Wayne everything that they
had done and what he ends up finding out
here is that indeed he did actually have
a brother who only lived for one night
he was basically born under duress the
child was hooked up to an incubator and
died within 12 hours
but the question cannot be helped but
ask what if it was all a cover what if
Thomas and Martha Wayne gave birth to a
son and then we're told well you know
your son has complications which they
witness those complications and the
doctor you know under orders from the
court of owls told Thomas and Martha
Wayne I'm sorry your child has passed
away there's nothing we can do
the child was effectively brought back
or taken by the court raised by the
court and then became Lincoln March all
the while being
told you our Thomas Wayne jr. you are
the rightful son of Thomas Wayne and
Martha Wayne you're the rightful heir to
the Wayne fortune and the Wayne family
Bruce Wayne can't help but wonder is any
of that true and Scott Snyder asks us
that question do you think it's true do
you really believe that Bruce Wayne
actually has a brother named Thomas the
issue with this is that we're never
given a definitive answer in the story
we're never told for any real measure of
certainty instead the mystery is just
kind of out there the question is just
kind of there and again it all really
kind of feeds back into this notion that
Bruce Wayne does not know Gotham City as
well as he thinks he does now again this
all feeds back into the whole notion I
guess the whole idea that Bruce Wayne
himself is still relatively new to the
role of Batman remember when the new 52
first started it's only been five years
since Bruce Wayne put on his cloak and
cowl for the very first time and became
Batman so you know he doesn't really
know Gotham as well as we would think he
would know in the classic Batman stories
before the new 52 okay so getting into
Batman death of the family I guess new
52 Batman death of the family keep in
mind guys for those of you guys who were
joining us for the very first time
anything marked new 52 comes before DC
rebirth again I'll have it before DC
rebirth in the playlist so you won't
have to feel confused or throw and offer
anything like that but death of the
family is probably one of the greatest
stories ever written in Batman history
to be honest with you guys I absolutely
love it because it really changes the
way we view the Joker right like
historically speaking the Joker
depending on what error you're reading
him has always been the sort of comedic
sometimes even slapstick character I
mean back when he first showed up and in
DC Comics he was very violent very dark
but because of the comics code he had to
be made a little more funny now of
course he was returned to his darker
roots under Neal Adams I think it was uh
but while the time Steve Englehart came
around that basically gave us Batman the
Animated Series Joker and so then of
course we saw his character kind of wax
and wane over the years and in the days
really kind of like the years leading up
to the launch of a new 52 the Joker was
still very much this somewhat you know I
guess a great blend of like evil and and
comedy but what this gives us here under
Scott Snyder is just a genuinely dark
and twisted Joker and the stories are
almost scary because of like how the
Joker is like it's almost terrifying you
know in a sense that Scott Snyder just
made himself fresh
and so fun and so interesting so um
there are a couple of things that I do
want to point out here for those of you
guys were really confused about Batman
with regards to like DC rebirth new 52
so on and so forth there really is no
classic Batman which is to say Batman
before the new 52 instead there's only
new 52 Batman but what DC did is they
sort of doing things like this in death
of the family and will start you know
talk we'll talk about these as we go
through the story but they basically
sort of grabbing you know comics and
grabbing events from the classic Batman
era and rolling them in and so that's
one of the things that kind of confuse
people about like the stance of Batman
the hard reboot that sort of thing but
the fact remains here that with regards
to the return of the Joker this is
twofold in Detective Comics number one
because with us this whole thing
starting when new 52 Batman first
started there was neither hide nor hair
of the Joker I mean he was just kind of
gone for a while the only appearance he
had was in Detective Comics number one
and that was in it was like just it was
your standard fare of Joker storytelling
it was the Joker who was engaging in a
scheme Batman was chasing after him it
was his cat-and-mouse game
the Joker was captured and that was in
but the story ended on this very image
Matic kind of tone where it seemed like
the Joker's face was basically removed
and then we didn't know what was gonna
happen after that like we had no idea
the Joker effectively just vanished like
that was it the Joker was gone you know
and so because that fans were just kind
of like where's the Joker
we want the Joker because the Joker is
is consistently ranked as the number one
greatest villain in comic books you know
just because of the fact that he's so
crazy is schemes are kind of nuts to do
such an interesting character but with
regards to his return here this came in
a beautiful way so initially we just
kind of pick up with Commissioner Gordon
and Harvey Bullock and a few other
people in the autumn City Police
Department nothing too major but the
power suddenly goes out now the backup
generators do come on but we get this
really eerie glimpse of the Joker just
standing in a hallway and that right
there really kind of hits to me as one
of the scariest things about the Joker
because it's scarier to me isn't like
the Joker copyrighting fish or it's
scarier to me than the Joker just going
on like a murder spree or anything like
that the fact that you would just like
the power would go down to a building
the generators would come on and you'd
look at the doorway and there would just
be this crazy guy with a hidden face
standing in the doorway that's just
terrifying to me what the Joker does is
he really just kind of like taunts Jim
Gordon and this is Scott Snyder saying
hey guys look this is the Joker that
we're getting now this is
Joker you're gonna see this is not the
crazy comedic Joker the one you're used
to from Batman the Animated Series this
is the dark sinister Joker this is the
one but you guys have always been
wanting to see the return to Batman
number one Joker the dark evil sadistic
you know do whatever it is that he wants
to do kind of version of his character
and so the crazy thing is that as he's
taunting Jim Gordon he's going around
and killing cops all around Jim Gordon
now this is designed to really kind of
be a throwback of sorts to Killing Joke
I guess in the sense that during The
Killing Joke story Jim Gordon was put on
this roller coaster of Terror and he was
made to view all these different images
of Barbara Gordon in a very vulnerable
state you know for the most part they
were naked images there was some
allusion to the idea that she had been
physically assaulted in multiple ways by
the Joker or the Joker's henchmen and
Jim Gordon was forced to look at these
different images as it was happening it
was very much a ride of absolute
insanity but it was the helplessness
that made that scene so you know
impactful in The Killing Joke and that's
what's happening here The Joker's
walking around in the pitch black
killing all these different cops under
the command of Jim Gordon and one he's
not quite paralyzed with fear but
there's nothing he can do to stop the
Joker because he can't find him he can't
see him and that's what makes things so
crazy is because once Batman shows up on
the scene we don't really know exactly
how he got there but presumably somebody
did something or Batman was just kind of
kind of patrolling or you just notice
the power went down at Gotham's a Gotham
City Police Department but once Batman
gets there of course he more or less
rescues Jim Gordon who's clearly shaken
by the ordeal but the Joker had also
stolen his face back now at this point
it's really just kind of an exercise
bye-bye Alfred and by Batman to really
just kind of figure out why the Joker
came back and that's one of the things
that makes his character so interesting
is because no one knows what the schemes
of the Joker are based on I mean for
God's sake he had a scheme called The
Laughing fish where he wanted to make
fish look like him and then copy write
them that was the scheme like that that
was its Joker storytelling is classic
Joker stuff and that's what makes him so
cool is because no one knows what he's
gonna do next now the funny thing about
this is Damian Wayne has never really
like encountered the Joker in a
tried-and-true fashion and so while he's
there watching the whole investigation
between Alfred and and Bruce Wayne you
know and while there you know Alfred and
Bruce are just talking about how
dangerous the Joker is and how they have
to tread carefully and things like that
Damian Wayne's ready to jump in
headstrong and I love this because I
feel like
moments like this really kind of give us
that um you know that kind of like yes
the Joker is dangerous the Joker is
someone to be afraid of because Batman's
warning today Mian is do not take the
Joker lightly yes he's got no powers
whatsoever he does not have
super-strength
he doesn't have SuperSpeed any of that
stuff but the fact that you never know
what he's going to do is what makes him
so dangerous nine times out of ten if
the Joker says he's going to do
something he's already done it and he's
just sending you on a wild goose chase
case in point
they basically interrupt a broadcast
made by a guy you know with the Joker's
just has this guy tied down to a chair
in the Joker's acting like you know his
arms the guy's arms or whatever you know
but what he basically says is that Mayor
Haiti is going to die at midnight now
this is not Scott Snyder going through
and just repeating the past he is but
he's doing it for a reason when I was
going to this story my first thought was
well this is just a throwback to Batman
number one right like to the Joker's
first appears I'm going to kill the
mayor at midnight
you know that kind of thing oh that's
not the case instead what happened in
originally in Batman number one is the
Joker was going to kill the mayor at
midnight but it was because he had
poisoned them 24 hours beforehand and
this story it's a lot more interesting
it's a lot more intriguing and it shows
us how smart the Joker is because
remember when the Joker first popped up
he was just a guy who dresses a clown
and did crazy things with regards to
this what we end up finding out is the
Joker actually poisoned Mayor Haiti
already but only with half the solution
necessary to kill him and it sense that
what are you done is he basically does
kind of like poison the chemical that
was used to mop the mayor's floor and
then you know dab some chemical onto the
clothing of the various police officers
who are guarding mayor Haiti and so
quite literally the police killed the
mayor in the sense that when the two
chemicals basically merged the chemical
on the clothing of the other cops and
the chemical the residue that's left
over from the from the floor when those
converged together it basically results
in everybody losing their minds
everybody being exposed to a version of
the Joker toxin now this is where Scott
Snyder begins to turn the story on its
head because we look at the Joker toxin
and it's inherently anis always really
been a toxin that kills people with just
this disgusting grin on their face with
this they die from frowns and so it's
really basically the Joker going through
and essentially committing his own
crimes but at the same time doing it in
such a way that is just a little bit
different from the way it was before now
the reason why this matters in the Reese
this is significant is because the Joker
is key to understanding the continuity
of Batman in the new 52 under normal
circumstances anybody would look at
Batman and say well he's just classic
Batman and for whatever reason made it
into the new 52 not at all
what do you see did when Batman was
first launched in new 52 is they said
okay Superman gets a hard reboot he's
totally reset this is a brand-new
Superman none of the things that
happened in classic DC happened in the
new 52 we're just going through his his
stories for the very first time the
flash it was the same way Wonder Woman
it was the same way all that stuff it
was the exact same way with Batman it
was not what DC started doing is they
said okay let's grab classic DC stories
like The Killing Joke and let's say it
took place in the new 52 and let's grab
classic stories like nightfall and let's
say it took place in the new 52 it took
place off panel and we didn't see that
story happen but it simply just is the
stories explained to have taken place in
the five years between the time when
Bruce Wayne first put on the cloak and
cowl and the modern day when his story's
picked up and so we were just kind of
told somewhere along the line The
Killing Joke happened somewhere along
the line nightfall happened and that's
kind of the cool thing here is because
what we're also told is that over the
course of Batman's history his first
encounter with the Joker as Red Hood
took place the first time or I guess you
know really when they met and it led to
Joker falling into this vat of chemicals
surviving and then coming out with green
hair and bleached skin that that
happened these are the kind of things
that sort of just got rolled into his
new 52 by grabbing classic DC stories
and making them official continuity in
DC and so again with Batman basically
you know going through and deciphering
these chemicals that were used by the
Joker and figuring out that the
composition spells out the words AC E
ace chemical once he gets there he
actually finds out that the Red Hood
that he sees is not the Joker instead of
course is Harley Quinn this is designed
as a distraction to remove Batman from
the equation but we end up finding out
the reason this is done is in order for
the Joker to basically kidnap Alfred
Pennyworth now anybody who knows
anything about Batman comics will tell
you that Alfred Pennyworth is the one
guy who's off-limits I mean you do not
touch out for pennyworth right like like
Alfred Mann he's the bro you know Alfred
is the bro you do not touch Alfred he's
just one of the coolest guys and so of
course with Alfred and age with Batman
effectively figuring out what's going on
pretty fast and with with the Joker
basically leaving behind a tape that
essentially just kind of taunts Batman
like
I have you know Alfred and so on and so
forth it sends Bruce into this almost a
maddening state not in the sense that he
loses his mind but in the sense that for
him
Alfred is the closest thing he has to a
father and to have this person taken
away by the Joker is like losing his
father all over again and so it really
sort of speeds up the timeline it moves
things into a really endurance based
motion because in his mind it's only a
matter of time before the Joker kills
Alfred but the question is what happens
between now and the time that Alfred
dies and that's what's the most
terrifying is because Batman has no
earthly clue what the Joker will do and
that's what makes the Joker so dangerous
with two faces he's probably just gonna
kill you with penguin is probably gonna
interrogate you for information
maybe ransom you or even puddle you know
possibly kill you there's a handful of
options that any of those guys might
consider but the Joker is so insane that
there's no telling what it is
that he's going to do now of course from
here it's a matter of targeting Jim
Gordon and that's essentially what's
happening now something that I want you
to keep in mind here is the way in which
Jim Gordon is poisoned he basically
receives a blood thinner at the hands of
the Joker and he just starts bleeding
out incredibly fast now the Joker did
that for a very particular reason and
we'll find that out here in a second and
again it really hits home at the idea of
the fact that the Joker is very
intelligent in terms of what he thinks
and in terms of what he does but
ultimately what ends up happening is
Batman essentially traces the Joker's
location down to a local bridge and the
reason why is because of the fact that
this is another one of the crimes that
Joker had committed now this is Scott
Snyder essentially telling us this is
what the motivation of the Joker is that
historically speaking Batman and Joker
have just kind of gone round and round
and round and round and that was really
yet you know the Joker would escape from
Arkham Asylum he would commit some
crimes Batman would chase him Batman
would catch him the Joker would be
arrested thorne Arkham Asylum and the
cycle would repeat that's just the way
the game was played but the funny thing
here is that the Joker more or less is
kind of reattaching his face with
strings even go so far as to taunt
Batman and say look this is the game we
play right I mean see the game that we
always play you know I go to a bridge
and I threaten to kill some people and
then you call in Nightwing and then
Nightwing saves the day and then you
defeat me and I go back to Arkham but
what if we didn't do that what if we
didn't play that game what if I just
basically killed him already
what if I decided to do that what if I
took the fun away from you now
the crazy thing about this is that
Joker's entire scheme here does have a
method to his madness and that's what
makes this so visceral that's what makes
it so interesting is that where he does
just dead make the bridge for the heck
of it and where Batman's entire plan
effectively just kind of goes up in
smoke the joker effectively takes him
captive and he really just kind of takes
Batman prisoner you know exposes him to
all these different - the - the Joker
toxin you know and it sends the
possibility or I guess that makes it a
possibility that Batman is effectively
poisoned by the Joker himself now the
other half of this is the Joker starts
to taunt Bruce with the idea that he's
like I know who you are like I know what
you're about
I left you my calling card you know he
target he starts referencing things like
the court of owls and so the Joker was
watching Batman in his whole court of
owls event he's been watching everything
happened the entire time you know and he
references things like The Killing Joke
he references things like nightfall he
references all these scenarios he talks
about Jim Gordon Oh Jim Gordon would
bleed for the city and that's why he
gave him a blood thinner was to
basically make him bleed for the city if
Jim Gordon wants to be a guy who's gonna
put his life on the line and bleed for
the city of Gotham then I will make it a
reality and that's what makes it so cool
is because the Joker is basically
grabbing these metaphors of what people
stand for and taking them from the realm
of being a metaphor and making them
literal but at the end of the day
Joker's argument - Batman is that PE
that Nightwing that Batgirl that you
know Jason Todd that Damian Wayne you
know they're all fake and like none of
them are real none of them are who they
really are and this again really hits
home - the idea of The Killing Joke all
it ever takes is just one bad day that
this one bad day wouldn't necessarily
send somebody into the realm of madness
it would reveal their true selves and
that's what the Joker's hitting out is
this is not who you really are this face
that you put on the face of Bruce Wayne
the face of Dick Grayson the face of
Barbara Gordon the faces that you wear
at night is who you really are you are
Batman Dick Grayson is Nightwing now
something to notice here is that he
never references any of them by name he
somebody just says I know who you are
but the bigger implication here is that
the Joker is kind of hitting home at
this idea that perhaps Batman really is
just an insane person that perhaps
Batman really is just crazy and so again
is this really really cool situation
that maybe the Joker is not as
as he seems that maybe the Joker is very
much a completely sane person but
ultimately the Joker is able to make his
escape and the reason why is of course
the Gotham police department shows up
but Joker has his own henchman and Joker
has those guys fire rockets you know at
the police cars and incapacitate them
and and that kind of thing and makes his
escape but what we end up having here is
Bruce Wayne waking up in the Batcave to
the other members of the bat family to
Red Hood to Red Robin Tim Drake to
Barbara Gordon bad girls to Dick Grayson
Nightwing and Damian Wayne and this is
really cool and this is where the death
of the family concept begins to come
into play because essentially what
happens here as Bruce Wayne basically
says somewhere along the line did Joker
access the Batcave I don't know how he
did it I don't know exactly you know
where or where he gained his entry point
but it seems to have been done through
me and what Bruce does is he references
this old instance where he and the Joker
were fighting on top of a blend of
course this is really kind of a
reference back to the older 1960s 1950s
Batman stories where the Joker was a
little more comedic but also a little
more sinister at the same time and
essentially what happened was the Joker
was presumed to have been defeated by
Batman after having fallen off the blimp
you know most likely to his death but
this is Bruce also acknowledging his
lack of experience the idea that will
the Joker's defeated time to go home and
that's really yeah and so of course you
know Batman had taken a route back to
the Batcave he tried to get some sleep
couldn't get any sleep at all came back
downstairs only to find that there was a
joker card laying in the Batcave in the
water and so of course again this is
cool because it's the Joker basically
saying I was here in the cave but even
then this goes back to the court of owls
right like it goes back to the whole
court of owls thing Bruce Wayne's like
no no the court of owls doesn't exist
because if it did I would have known
about it I would have discovered them
the fact that I know Gotham as well as I
do and the fact that I can't verify the
court of owls is real indicates to me
that they're not it's Bruce Wayne's own
arrogance is his own hubris that always
seems to get the better of him in this
scenario he's just like well it probably
stuck to like the boat or something like
that right like there's no way the Joker
would have gotten into the Batcave
because surely if the Joker knew what
our identities were he would have
targeted us individually but that is
what makes the Joker so dangerous is
because maybe he does know the identity
of Bruce Wayne maybe he does know the
identity of Dick Grayson and Barbara
Gordon and all these guys maybe he does
know who they truly are maybe he's been
watching them every step of their lives
for the last year and chose not to
do anything that's what makes him so
dangerous is because there's no way to
know for sure there's no way to know
with an absolute certainty and so what
happens is of course Batman's
investigations ultimately lead him back
to Arkham Asylum and this is really
Scott Snyder kind of hitting hitting
back at Grant Morrison's story Arkham a
serious house on serious earth which
between the storytelling and the art
that story is a descent into absolute
madness I mean that story is insane if
you ever get to read it sometime I feel
like that's the story they would make
schizophrenic screen under the belief
that it would cure them like it's just
it's it's almost like like turn of the
20th century attempts to cure a mental
illness it's just one of the most insane
things that you're ever going to see I
couldn't begin to wrap my head around it
like I had to put it down I was like all
right I am dying to hear this story is
crazy as hell but from what I understand
if you finish it out all the way it's an
amazing story doesn't like keep hearing
people keep telling me it's one of the
greatest stories ever told and I feel
like I should try to read it all the way
through but it's Batman makes his way
through Arkham Asylum the reason why I
say it's a serious house and serious
earth but kind of a tribute to that is
because from what I did read through
Sirius houseless we're sort of it's like
a gauntlet right it's like Batman going
against a bunch of his rogues and
different things like that the inmates
of Arkham are essentially allowed to go
free Batman has to face off against them
all working his way all the way down to
the secret of what becomes origin is
really like and it's very much the same
way in this story he's going against the
inmates of Arkham Asylum he's going
against some of the major criminals
two-face penguin people who have allied
themselves with the Joker along the way
but as he gets through this he's of
course kind of forced to look at this
tapestry of experiences and this is why
I say this is where DC started grabbing
things from classic DC and rolling them
into the history of new 52 Batman the
scene where the fisherman is holding up
the fish to Batman that's from The
Laughing fish the death of Jason Todd
these are all moments that come from
Batman's whole experience near the
various escapades that he's been a part
of in relation to the Joker as well as
his own stories and so again is DC
basically taking these classic DC
stories and saying these have now
happened in the new 52 they just
happened off panel we didn't see them
take place it has happened sometime in
the past and so again after going
through these various guys these various
members of Arkham Asylum some of whom
are dressing as villains some of whom
are not ultimately comes across this
kind of really weird screwed up version
of of
Justice League which is really kind of
crazy I mean it's essentially just
employees of Arkham who have no families
nobody would notice them missing and
wouldn't have any questions as to why
they're not there but this is designed
for the purpose of kind of forcing Bruce
Wayne's aunt you know essentially saying
look you know each one of these guys is
going to try to pick up the sword in the
stone so to speak but it's going to
administer an electric shock every time
they do and it's going to kill them so
either you can go through and you can
sit in the chair you know sit on sit on
your throne so to speak and spare their
lives or you can watch as each one of
them dies and so of course ultimately
Batman elects to sit on the chair and
that's really the end of that he's you
know more or less electrocuted and
knocked unconscious now of course when
he comes to he is directly in you know
this cave as it's being held or I guess
as he's being being held by the Joker
directly this is the Joker being
sadistic and twisted this is the Joker
basically saying look these faces of the
people that you wear that's not who you
really are your face is Batman your face
is is Nightwing your face is Barbara
Gordon and symbolically he's literally
cutting their faces off and serving them
to them and that's the initial
implication here of course Alfred having
been Joker eyes essentially you know
having experienced exposure to the Joker
toxin but when these different trays are
opened up the idea seems to be that the
faces of of Barbara Gordon Nightwing
Damian Wayne so on and so forth those
faces have all been cut off and they're
being served to them and so again it's
it's really twisted but it also falls in
line with a complete insanity of the
Joker in the sense that this does not
make sense to anybody but himself
it's just so dark and just so gruesome
now of course in the end Batman really
just kind of calls it a day you know
we're all these different guys where
there's they're effectively soaked with
gasoline
there's Flint's under their chairs so
they try to move it'll set the chairs on
fire and it'll basically burn them alive
the flame is thrown Joker intends to
kill them Batman knocks the Joker out of
the way and a fight ensues now of course
this also leads to Batman freeing out
you know freeing the various members of
the bat family all of whom are exposed
to the Joker toxin once the Joker's too
had a cat explodes and it's kind of
crazy to see because what this does is
it shows us their ability to overcome
the Joker toxin in the sense that he was
really more designed to kind of wreak
havoc on them as opposed to actually
kill them but at the same time the fight
between the Joker and Batman has some
measure of finality now it's not going
to be as final as like Batman in game
right but it still has some
a finality because what that man does is
he turns the tables on the Joker and
that's what makes it so interesting that
Masek we says you know You Know Who I am
and that's cool but I know who you are
I know what your name is now the
implication here in terms of how this
unfolds by Scott Snyder really seems to
point at the idea that the Joker is a
very lonely human being right like the
Joker wants somebody else in his life
somebody as crazy as he is
somebody that views the world the same
way he does that the face it he wears is
simply a mask hence the reason he cut
his face off and had it reattached you
know by virtue of strings and staples
that he's trying to get Batman and Dick
Grayson and I guess Batman and Nightwing
and these other members of the bat
family to be the same as him but with
Batman essentially confronting him and
saying I know what your name is I know
who you're I know what your secret is
it's almost like it's this idea that the
Joker wants to stay crazy the Joker
doesn't want to know who he is now of
course this is going to hit home to the
idea of end game and to kind of talk
about that a second because we'll
refresh that once we get to endgame the
whole idea in the Joker's mind is that
he and Batman share relationship that
nobody else will have that is just part
of what they do they just go round and
round and round and round The Joker
escapes Arkham he's caught by Batman and
the cycle continues and that's it that's
their thing it's their stick it's what
they do this possibility of Batman
growing away from the Joker this
possibility of Batman walking away from
the Joker becoming something greater
than what the Joker considers him to be
could ultimately mean there would be no
more Joker Batman dichotomy instead it
would just beat the Joker running from a
guy who's not chasing after him anymore
and so again the Joker's effectively
trying to kind of twist Batman trying to
make him into somebody who's crazy
trying to make him question everything
about himself especially the possibility
that his identity might be out there but
ultimately the Joker really just kind of
like falls off a cliff and that's
basically it I mean the the indication
here is that the Joker is essentially
dead that seems to be what it is that
happens where the very Lisa does kind of
vanishes but of course we know that
he'll make his return an end game which
is probably one of the greatest stories
that was ever written by Scott Snyder
with regards to Batman
but again what also happens is in these
last few pages of this story when the
rest of the bat family is freed when
they're basically treated to overcome
their exposure to the Joker toxin Bruce
Wayne tells Alfred that he had
previously gone to Arkham Asylum under
the guise of making charitable
contributions when he confronted the
Joker after the Joker is supposedly left
his calling card in the back
and Bruce Wayne confronted the Joker
with a card and the Joker pretended like
like he had no idea the Joker gave off
the indication that he had no idea who
Bruce Wayne was but that's why this is
so important is because if all the Joker
cares about is Batman and the Joker
doesn't care about Bruce Wayne Bruce
Wayne's not relevant to him so long as
Bruce Wayne stays the Batman and that's
all he cares about that's all he wants
and so again it's really this idea that
it's all about the Joker reacting to who
it is that Bruce Wayne really is and in
his mind Bruce Wayne is really Batman
you know Bruce Wayne is not Bruce Wayne
but the philanthropist the billionaire
that's the face that's the costume the
actual person that's Batman and so
because that it's it's a really really
cool exploration into the mind of the
Joker to a degree in terms of how he
have used the world around him but
ultimately because of the fact that that
Batman simply didn't reveal to the other
members of the bat family that the Joker
had broken in to to the Batcave the
Joker had accessed their identities
seems to be what really puts the nail in
the coffin of the bat family hence the
name death of the family because in
their minds it was an extreme betrayal
of trust that if the Joker knew who they
were individually the Joker would just
track them all down he would destroy
their personal lives he would kill
everybody around them that they cared
about that they knew about and so again
Batman keeping this hidden meant that at
the end of the day he still didn't trust
each of these members of the bat family
despite everything they've been through
all the fights they've been in all the
conflicts they'd worked on together
Batman still didn't trust who they were
and so it's really just kind of him
showing where he is what he's about and
for the most part everybody except Dick
Grayson really kind of leaves him
hanging okay so when it comes to Batman
I mean covering in game you know when it
comes to Batman
it's a very weird situation and the
reason why is because of well because of
Dark Side war Dark Side war was
basically the story that just threw a
wrench in everything right because you
had like Superman stories and you had
Green Lantern stories and you had Wonder
Woman stories and flash stories so on
and so forth and then suddenly it was
Darkseid war now for a lot of people or
for a lot of characters it sort of made
sense but for Batman it caused all kinds
of problems and this is really where the
continuity sort of comes into play with
the whole DC you creativity over
continuity and what-have-you but truth
be told if we wanted to if we so chose
we could just ignore Batman in game
we'd be ignoring an amazing story but we
could ignore Batman in-game or we can
try to figure out where Batman in-game
fits in this game of continuity with
regards to DC Comics so my initial
thought on this is that if we had to
kind of find a place to put it what we
could do is we could basically argue
that Dark Side war takes place between
between death of the family and endgame
or we could say it takes place after
endgame at some point in time we don't
really know at that point is Batman's
interest in the Joker is still prevalent
though during the events of Dark Side
war and so it would make sense that it
could possibly take place before Batman
in game the problem with this is that if
it did take place before Batman in game
then we would have seen it reference to
in Batman in game and so that's one of
the crazy things that goes on with
regards little creativity versus
continuity so at the end of the day
we're just gonna go ahead and like tack
this on as the story before the events
of a very you know really before going
into DC rebirth there are a couple of
stories like I don't think graveyard
shift is one of them I think the next
one is bloom and the one after that is
epilogue but those are not wildly
important um those are really just kind
of stories that are there for the
offering of Bruce Wayne with regards to
the whole DC you Jim Gordon Batman but
that was not a really well-received line
of storytelling so we can just kind of
pretend like that didn't really happen I
enjoyed it but you know for the sake of
continuity we're really not gonna worry
about that too much but if dr. mains
here Batman in game is exactly what it
sounds like right I mean it's it's the
final event of the Batman comics I mean
I know we did in game at one point on my
channel here before those videos that I
had scripted I think those videos sucked
and so we're going back here and we're
just redoing it because I think this is
better and so because of that with
regards to the whole Batman in game
landscape it creates a really
interesting scenario with regards to
this final battle between Joker and
Batman and that was really the nature of
what it was that Scott Snyder was
hitting on Batman and the Joker are the
one-two punch of comic books and the
reason why is because of the fact that
the Joker is the most popular villain
and comic books I mean consistently
rated and number one at the top of
everyone's list the Joker is popular
because he's funny because he's
dangerous because he's kooky crazy no
one knows what it is that he's gonna do
the other half of this is that Batman is
rapidly becoming a superhero kusa the
top of almost everyone's list I mean he
consistently outs all Superman's comics
the
the exception to that is right now in DC
rebirth where I think the Superman is
outselling Batman because the comics are
so good but during the new 52
Batman was outselling Superman by about
50,000 issues a month it was crazy how
how much better he was doing but the
fact remains that when it comes to these
two characters they're just kind of the
one-two punch of DC when it's good guys
and bad guys and because of that it was
always like the two went hand in hand
you could not have Batman without the
Joker you couldn't reboot Batman without
reintroducing the Joker somewhere online
Scott Snyder draws on that and says the
relationship between Batman and Bruce
Wayne transcends comics it transcends
the Joker schemes it goes into this
realm of something eternal it goes into
this realm in this you know eternal
battle between good and evil because
that's what it represents and so picking
up with this whole end game conflict we
initially joined Alfred Pennyworth
giulia Pennyworth and in Bruce Wayne now
Julia pennyworth we can reference here
but we don't really need to know much
about her and the reason why is because
she has banished in DC rebirth as far as
I'm aware as far as I'm aware she is
gone never be seen or heard from again
and so because of this during the events
of Batman eternal which was basically
this year-long story that took place
between the events of death of the
family and Emma game
Julia pennyworth was introduced as this
girl who was the alleged daughter of
Alfred Pennyworth and Alfred basically
had a broader in she became a part of
the bat family but she was really more
of like the information backup she was
really one that was just kind of there
operating behind the scenes very much in
the same capacity that we were
traditionally used to seeing Alfred
Pennyworth perform and so really she's
just kind of like the information person
think of her as a less significant
smaller version of like Oracle from
Batman from Barbara Gordon when she was
in a wheelchair so in the middle of
their whole conversing and talking and
so on and so forth Batman's immediately
attacked by Wonder Woman now that's what
makes this so cool is because of the
fact that this is basically Batman
taking on the entirety of the Justice
League now Batman fighting the Justice
League raises as many questions as it
answers because if you talk to any
Batman fan they'll tell you oh yeah
Batman would easily be able to say on
Justice League
no questions asked I know that because I
like him but if you were to talk to like
a Wonder Woman fan they'll say no no
Batman could never take out the Wonder
Woman Wonder Woman's way too capable
she's way too strong I know that because
I like her
Superman the flash Green Lantern the
whole nine yards people just stick with
the comic book fans that
they enjoy the most for example I'll say
that forevermore that Professor X is the
only good leader of the x-men nobody
will ever be as good as him I don't care
what people do with Cyclops but the fact
remains here that for the character of
Bruce Wayne one thing that Scott
Snyder's been doing the entire time is
just building on the nature of him his
intelligence what he's capable of so on
and so forth and it's very much a
reference to Tower of Babel for those of
you guys who don't know tower of Babel
was a story that we did a video on but
it basically detailed the idea that
Batman had these different protocols
more or less on how to take down each
member of the Justice League but with
regards to this scenario it really just
kind of pops out of nowhere and so
Batman doesn't really have time to enact
these protocols and an argument could be
made that with regards to this being the
new 52 that maybe no such protocols
actually exist but regardless of the
scenario he does know how to take down
these different members of the Justice
League he does know how to incapacitate
them with the character of Wonder Woman
hand-to-hand combat is out of the
question Bruce Wayne just does not have
the capacity to take her on she is a
warrior first and a woman second and so
because of that the ability to reason
with her isn't there because she's not
in her right mind she's not in control
of her full faculties and so as a result
Bruce Wayne's basically required to kind
of bring in this giant mecha-suit and he
does what he can he's able to hold her
off to a degree but then we actually
have her you know what she's kind of
defeated to a degree we actually have
the flash jumping into the scene now of
course this defeat of the flash is super
quick I mean it's just some kind of
liquid on the ground that's basically
slick and it sends flash careening into
a building and that's really it but
notice Bruce Wayne does this he
incapacitates each member of the Justice
League in relation to what way is
easiest to subdue the flash runs so put
him on a ground is too slick for him to
gain any traction on and suddenly he
might as well just be skating on ice
Wonder Woman is a warrior grab a suit
that will allow him to basically combat
her you know using hand-to-hand combat
Aquaman is essentially a fish out of
water I don't care what anybody says
it's the nature of his character you
know put him in a situation to where he
basically will not be able to access
water and eventually you'll start
wreaking havoc on his body structure
Superman is the kicker and the reason
why is because after all these members
of the Justice League had been defeated
Superman arrives on the scene now this
goes without saying historically
speaking you allow any Batman story any
Batman line of comics to go on long
enough
Batman and Superman will fight it's just
the nature of the beast it's the way it
goes it's just every single time it
always happens that way because we like
to see them fight I love to see Batman
and Superman fight but it always ends up
going that route now with regards to
Superman's arrival here uh what we're
also basically shown is that the Justice
League is not in their right mind
because of the fact that the Justice
League have been Joker eyes they have
been infected with the Joker toxin now
this creates an even more dangerous
situation because it's not as though you
know Batman just there's not like you
know he just like stole Lois Lane from
Superman right it's all he's just like
your girl's mind now and he just ran off
with Lois Lane and that's the end of
that and she just bailed out on Superman
that's not the case you know he can't
talk Superman down he can't rationalize
with Superman he's just running amok
he's doing what he's told by the joke
Reese's influenced by the Joker's
schemes and fighting against Bruce Wayne
the caveat to this comes in the caveat
of every Batman fight when it comes to
Superman invoking kryptonite I cannot
think of really any major circumstance
where Batman has fought Superman and
kryptonite has not been invoked in some
form or fashion and so because of this
we basically have Batman using
kryptonite gum more or less it's
basically gone that has kryptonite
particles that he just spits to the eye
of Superman and that's how he brings
Superman down that's really yet but it
also makes sense I mean that's the
struggle that you have when you have a
Batman and Superman a story with the two
of them are going to fight the question
is how do you have a man who's really
smart and really good at fighting but
has the normal strength and abilities of
a regular human being going against a
veritable god how do you in that story
effectively you do it the only way you
can do and you use kryptonite that is
the crux of every argument when it comes
to your Batman vs Superman on every form
everywhere across the world it's always
the idea well what if that man didn't
have kryptonite it's like well then he
would probably die and that thought
would be over really really quick and it
wouldn't be interesting at all and so
because of that we always you know end
up seeing kryptonite invoked here but
with the idea of the Joker basically
Joker rising the Justice League once
they're defeated and turned it's now on
Batman to begin going through and
finding out why now the reason why this
is such a huge deal is because for the
most part the Justice League have never
really been subdued by the Joker now
what this tells us is the lengths the
Joker's going to go to in order to try
to get his hands on Batman
in order to basically take this nail
from the realm of being a hey let's just
run around and get into a fight to the
realm of actually being a dangerous
scenario but at this point we transition
over to what's left of Arkham Asylum now
the reason why I say that is because
during the story Batman eternal which
basically dealt with the idea of hush
rallying the various Batman villains and
facing off against Bruce Wayne Arkham
Asylum was destroyed in its entirety now
there were a few of the things that went
into that but ultimately it led to Wayne
Manor being confiscated and then
transformed into a new Arkham Asylum and
so with that in mind one of the
orderlies who had worked in Arkham was a
guy by the name of Eric border now eric
border had about five comic book
appearances prior to this particular
story and eric was just a guy that
Batman had worked with occasionally
where they were trying to access like
this cell of the Joker or something
along those lines but Eric was always a
background character that nobody ever
had any reason to question he would just
kind of show up for a little bit and
then he would do something and then that
would really be it he was as forgettable
as virtually any other character in
comics the great thing about Snyder
writing is he says yeah but remember
that really forgettable guy what if he
was a very important guy and what we end
up having here is Batman just kind of
making his way through Arkham eventually
locked in a cell by Eric only for Eric
to basically reveal the fact that he is
the Joker and so essentially what's been
happening this entire time you know
throughout all the Batman comics
following the events of death of the
family as the Joker has been there
watching Batman every step of the way
the Joker's been walking around Arkham
Asylum every step of the way and no one
ever had any reason to believe it was
him now there were a couple of steps
that the Joker took in order to pull
this off the first was to basically use
what amounted to muscle relaxers in
order to keep his grin from giving him
away the other half was you know
changing the color of his hair changing
the color of his skin pigmentation or at
least covering his skin pigmentation and
making himself look like a normal person
but the reason why this is such a huge
deal and the reason why this was so
significant when it happened was because
of the fact that historically speaking
the Joker has always just sort of been
viewed as this nonsensical comedic
character where he just kind of engages
in these goofy stupid acts he's not too
bright he's certainly not something you
know insane criminal genius he's just a
guy that you know does stuff Batman
chases after him or you know Joker gets
locked in Arkham Asylum he escapes and
the story continues again what Scott
Snyder is basically telling us here
is that the Joker is not some buffoon
he's not the same kind of goof that
we've always thought he's been instead
he's a lot smarter than he's previously
been given credit for he's a lot smarter
than we would traditionally think him to
be in the sense that he was basically
able to trick everybody including the
world's greatest detective into
believing that he's either dead or he's
only just sitting underground when he
was among them the entire time and
that's one of the reasons why that's so
cool and so with that man effectively
you know locked in a Cell the idea is
that the Joker is essentially going to
run amok throughout the entirety of
Gotham City he's going to unleash
absolute pandemonium and absolute chaos
now the problem with this little bit of
storytelling here is that Snyder kind of
has to jump around a bit and the reason
why is because of the fact that I would
imagine that to a degree this story was
probably fast-tracked if I were gonna be
honest with the eyes I would imagine
Batman in game was probably slated to be
a seven or eight issue story arc and I
certainly think it would have helped to
flesh out some of the the small little
tidbits here and there but in this
instance we don't know how Batman got
out of his cell in Arkham Asylum he just
did now with regards to Scott Snyder you
know having this happen
he doesn't in a couple different ways
he's like look guys it's Batman he's
gonna find a way out I mean it's you
know he's not gonna be stuck in a prison
cell forever especially not the prison
cell of the old Arkham Asylum that he'd
visited so many times before surely he
would just have to know the ins and outs
and he would always have a way out and
even if he didn't he would just find a
way out for himself whether it's using
something out of his infinitely stored
utility belt to blow the hole in a wall
or whatever the case may be he would
always end up finding a way out of his
captivity and ultimately go free and so
the question that ends up coming to
fruition here is if the citizens of
Gotham City are basically losing their
minds if they are being exposed to a
Joker toxin well then why don't we just
cure it under normal circumstances that
would be the case the Joker has been
using the Joker toxin so many tons it'd
be very easy to cure it'd be very easy
to eliminate the problem with this is
that there has been a new ingredient
added to the Joker toxin that Batman
cannot account for which means that it
can't just be cured not only that the
true spooky nature of the Joker begins
to come into fruition when we have
Commissioner Gordon just looking over
all these different details and stories
and so on of the Joker's past and what
we end up finding out is that over the
last you know some odd
few hundred years or so in all these
major calamities and all these major
events and all these different terrible
scenarios and in everyday life or when
random pictures were taken we ultimately
ended up finding that Joker was there
now if what's being done in this picture
is absolutely true what we're seeing is
true that it means that the Joker is
some two hundred years old which is
absolutely mind-blowing
in terms of how it all unfolds because
then the question becomes if the Joker's
two hundred years old then what does
that mean for the character of Batman
you know does it mean that Bruce Wayne's
just kind of living this repetitive life
or does it mean that someone like Bruce
Wayne has always been there taken bath
the Joker again it raises a lot of these
really interesting questions when it
comes to the two characters because what
Scott Snyder was kind of da ting in was
this idea that the Joker could in fact
be this eternal god of chaos this
eternal God of destruction now it does
beg a few questions in terms of you know
how it comes together I mean this
story's older we've done this video
before we're just kind of remastering it
now so we really know how it ends but
you just kind of let ourselves live in
the moment for a second it really is
kind of a cool scenario because it begs
the question if the Joker is the god of
chaos if he was the god of order and
absolute destruction then how would that
unfold is he like an entity is he an
essence that just takes over one host
after another you know or is he
legitimately immortal will he always end
up just kind of being reincarnated and
you know his body will always resurrect
itself how does that all come together
that mystery that intrigue that kind of
Wow one of the world's going on the
cloak-and-dagger element of the Joker's
past is what makes this so possible
because no one knows the tried and true
story of the Joker
there's some origins that have more
credibility than others The Killing Joke
for example the Joker having been Red
Hood but the question is is that true or
is it just an idea that's maintained
because no one knows the right answer is
that answer used in place of the
absolute truth it's basically supplying
the best thing we can offer for an
answer
because we don't know what the real
answer is and so following this if the
Joker's effectively waging a one-man war
against everything that Batman knows and
loves and that's the basis behind this
that's the nature of this Bruce Wayne is
basically forced to see a repeat of his
own past in the form of Joe Chill now
for the living guys who are reading
all-star Batman right now this is one of
the reasons why we're doing Batman in
game and this is one of the reasons why
the question of Batman in game kanu ax T
comes into play because what
end up having is the introduction of
Duke now of course Duke is basically a
boy who's forced to witness the same
word he'll force to experience the same
kind of a violent scenario as the
parents of Bruce Wayne in the sense that
he's forced to possibly witness his own
parents being killed now of course
Batman jumping into the fray Batman
stopping the Joker eyes Joe Chill allows
Duke's parents to live the issue with
this is that they're exposed to the
Joker toxin and there doesn't seem to be
any way to cure it they're effectively
lost and so of course Bruce Wayne grabs
Duke and they associate a Koff that's
how Duke gets introduced to DC Comics
and that's why he plays a pretty
significant role in the life of Bruce
Wayne because his origin is almost
identical to the origin of Jason Todd in
the pre-crisis era of Dick Grayson you
know before crisis on Infinite Earths
and after crisis on Infinite Earths he
owed the idea that they had lost their
parents under some you know violent
circumstance and they're effectively
left an orphan just like Bruce Wayne not
only that these lengths that the Joker
will go to to secure his own ends you
know to secure his campaign are shown to
have virtually no limits I mean there
are babies that are Joker eyes which is
pretty twisted and pretty screwed up you
know but of course where Jim Gordon is
is essentially making this occasion
where he's talking directly to to Bruce
Wayne saying hey look you know the Joker
almost caught me the Joker almost killed
me I managed to subdue him ultimately
you know the Joker effectively comes
back then ends up taking out
Commissioner Gordon not really
permanently not really killing him I
mean he stabs him in the chest with a
with an axe so you would think that
would basically get him killed but then
we end up having you know if we end up
having Commissioner Gordon just kind of
pop up with his Joker toxin now again at
this point it's doing what can be done
in order to stem the tide of absolute
chaos of Gotham City and that's really
the significance of this moment is
because the city's just devolving into
complete and total pandemonium you have
soldiers who are Joker eyes and they're
just riding around in tanks carrying out
the Joker's wishes and wants you have
people who are just ripping the town
apart I mean it's just absolutely nuts
and it's a really really cool moment to
see and it's a really cool bit of chaos
that goes on here and the reason why is
because there's always been this sort of
decorum with the Batman landscape right
like like things get close you know
things that close to the point where
maybe Gotham is a little bit beyond
redemption maybe it's a little bit
beyond hope but it never quite crosses
that line the city of Gotham never quite
steps off that ledge there's really no
one to push it there and an argument
could be made that all the Joker's
really doing here is
exposing Gotham for what it really is a
city that's just slowly spiraling out of
control and Batman doing the best he can
to stem the flow but what happens when
this wall that's got these few punctures
here and there and water spewing in and
Batman's keeping the water coming in
with a little bits of gum what happens
when somebody starts blowing a hole in
that wall well there's no one to stem
the tide he's basically just revealing
Gotham for its true nature the insanity
of the city the fact that it's beyond
any real measure of hope the fact that
it is a city that's quite literally just
in a state of self destruction now of
course Bruce Wayne's journeys and his
desire to try to figure out what's going
on with this hidden chemical compound is
in this virus brings him to a villain by
the name of crazy quilt now as far as
I'm aware crazy quilt as he exists here
in the new 52 is a wholly new creation
or kind of a rework by Scott Snyder but
this is the first time we've seen him of
course he's a Jack Kirby character that
goes all the way back to really before
the new 52 and maybe even shortly after
crisis on Infinite Earths possibly even
before um but this is really just kind
of like a new iteration of him but he's
really just a guy who's kind of obsessed
with you know with with you know science
and medicines and studies and so on and
so forth but he's a guy who always sort
of felt like you is playing second
fiddle and kind of left out of this
bigger circle of Greater guys you know
in comparison like Hugo Strange and dr.
death and so on and so forth because
those are scientists in the community of
villains who are viewed to be the best
of their sort crazy quilts just kind of
consider to be like this B or C less guy
and so what he's really doing here and
the reason why he's allied himself with
the Joker is to try to solidify himself
as being one of the foremost scientists
in the realm of villainy and the
motivation behind this is a chemical
that's called Dionysian now this is
where Scott Snyder begins to move the
story away from like mythology and you
know weird mystery and intrigue and
possibly even some some ghost
storytelling and basically moves it back
into the realm and brings it back to
being grounded in science and in reality
and structure at least as close as you
can get to reality with a comic book but
what Snyder also does is he invokes guys
like Vandal Savage he invokes guys like
Ra's al Ghul and he says these are not
just mystical beings you know Vandal
Savage is not some guy who is just
inherently immortal it doesn't work that
way Ra's al Ghul is not a guy who just
stumbled across a Lazarus Pit one day
and just sort of dippin himself in it
the reason why they are immortal is
because of Dionysian but Vandal Savage
was the
first and only person to encounter
Dionysian in its most pure form Ra's al
Ghul found it but it's corrupted and
it's the reason for why whenever he
Dells himself into the pool he comes out
with temporary madness the Dionysian
that the Joker uses is an even more
impure version and that's something that
I hope you noticed that it's basically
stages of impurity that move you closer
and closer to madness the most pure
version has no side effects of complete
madness an impure version or Realty a
relatively impure version can bring you
a temporary madness as in the form of
someone who emerges out of the of the
Lazarus pits and if a version is too
impure it'll simply drive you insane
which seems to be the case with the
Joker now of course with regards to
Dekker himself the motivation here is
that he was basically told by the Joker
look if you help me out I will give you
Dionysian it'll effectively make you
immortal and you can use this substance
for whatever you no desire whatever a
dream it is that you have of course
against the wishes of Batman he injects
himself with this syringe and ultimately
his body begins breaking down on the
really on the on the genetic level on
the cellular level and he really just
kind of goes to pieces now of course
this is really Snyder kind of giving us
a timetable
it's him fast tracking things what we
end up finding out here is that with
regards to the Joker himself in terms of
like the pale man mythos it's what he's
been building on his entire life and his
entire existence and we'll get more to
that once we get closer to the ending of
this story but the reason why this is
fast-tracked and the reason why we're
given a really quick timetable is
because we're seeing what the end result
of smudger
to this virus is going to be there's
effectively a 24-hour window between the
time that a person is exposed to the
virus and the time that a person ends up
with the same fate as crazy cruel the
reason why he died so fast is because he
had it immediately ingested into his
bloodstream whereas individuals who
breathe it in as a gas have a little bit
more time before they effectively die
and so because of this Batman takes the
only route that he can take in terms of
trying to find out what Dionysian is if
it even really exists in Gotham City and
he travels back to the court of owls now
remember the court of owls was this
organization that had existed for
hundreds of years we talked about that
with regards to our court of owls and
Night of owls story it was an
organization that had been existing as
part of the criminal underworld in
Gotham for hundreds of years and Batman
didn't know about it but the talents do
have access to something that is
effectively able to resurrect
the debt this of course leaves Batman to
ask the question what is going on what
do you guys know about this substance
have you ever used it now of course this
is again confirmation of the fact that
the court of owls uses Dionysian to
basically resurrect those individuals
who were talents and then have them work
for the court themselves in addition to
the electrum chemical that they have
ingested inside of their body by virtue
of their bloodstream and long term
exposure again we covered that in our
video about night of owls but the fact
remains here that in the eyes of the
court the court are actually ready to
let Gotham City die and that's really
kind of the crazy situation about this
is because you would think that it would
just simply be a mutual desire to keep
that city going but that's not the case
the court basically makes the argument
look this city is going to die I mean
this city is gonna be destroyed it'll be
rebuilt once the Joker leaves and then
we will again be rulers of this city
once it comes back to the way that is
supposed to be we were literally guided
and and molded into the image that we
desire and so because of that you know
what we end up having is the Joker
essentially sneaking in the Batcave
again this is basically Scott Snyder
grabbing all these different elements
crowding all these different things or
the instance where Batman had talked
about how somewhere along the line the
Joker had gained access to the Batcave
it's a reference to this yet again the
Joker has gained access to the Batcave
again the difference here is that Alfred
tries to take him out with a shotgun now
this is kind of cool
because this is Alfred being pretty
hard-ass and we really kind of know that
with his character when it comes down to
it Alfred's got it where it counts he's
not the strongest he's not the best
fighter but come hell or high water he
will protect the Batcave and Batman as
best he can and so Alfred of course his
hand is chopped off now this is why I
say we can really kind of look at the
idea of endgame and we can determine its
continuity for ourselves because al firs
hand is not cut off in DC rebirth his
hand is well intact and unless he
managed to grow a new one I do not
believe there's an explanation of how
this reconciles with the existing Batman
continuity I think it's just kind of
ignored and it just really just kind of
left there um it may have been
reattached in a story that I'm not
familiar with but as far as I'm aware
like it was just cut off and that was
really the end of that but with the
Joker kind of going through with this
massive parade throughout Gotham City as
grotesque as it is ultimately the bat
family kind of stems things off as best
they can they do what they can to kind
of save the day but it ultimately comes
down to Batman actually making friends
with the various members of its rogues
gallery and again this is really one of
those
scenarios worse just a mutually assured
destruction em ad if they don't act
together and so it's really in the best
interest of the various villains poison
ivy Clayface so on and so forth
to work together in order to bring the
Joker down now this also begins the
process of us being able to see Clayface
become a good guy and that's one of the
cool things it's slow it's a very very
slow build but these are the baby steps
these are the things that eventually
lead into that and so what is I'm
happening is of course Batman comes up
with a plan because as Batman and he's
always got a plan and the story's got to
end somehow and so one of them happening
here is it's really like Dick Grayson
dresses Batman serving to distract the
Joker and where the Joker initially
believes he's effectively taking control
of that man basically hasn't held
captive ultimately when the ruse is
revealed and it turns out to be Dick
Grayson the Joker immediately picks up
on the fact that Batman's found
dionisije him and so of course with the
various bombs planted around the die and
you see em - Lee having been not really
deactivated but basically kind of held
off by Julia pennyworth what this does
is it leads to a final confrontation
between the Batman and the Joker now the
reason why this is so huge and the
reason why this is so important is
because Scott Snyder is doing a lot more
than just saying and it's Batman and the
Joker fighting each other it's not like
that instead this battle is designed to
represent every ounce of conflict the
two have ever had every instance where
they've ever fight going all the way
back to Batman number one every instance
where the Joker and Batman have come
together they've engaged in some
campaign and the Joker's defeated and he
goes to Arkham Asylum this is designed
to be the story to end all stories the
battle to end all battles between the
Joker and Batman in the traditional
sense now as we know in DC rebirth we
will see like the three Joker's that's
really what's just kind of being hinted
at that's a story that's gonna be given
to us and that of course comes out of
Darkseid war again a little bit of a
kind of a continuity going back and
forth but even the Joker himself really
kind of makes comments to the idea that
it is it's almost comedic they've been
fighting for so long they've been
enemies for so long this was really the
only end result this is Scott Snyder
hitting to the idea of like The Killing
Joke right you know when Batman goes and
he sits down and he talks to the Joker
and says you know if we keep going one
of us is going to die it's grabbing all
these themes of Batman throughout the
decades of his storytelling and bringing
them all together into one cohesive
story and saying this was the most
logical outcome somewhere
on the line there was going to be a
battle to the death between Batman and
the Joker now the funny thing about this
is that the Joker's sanity were at the
very least what seems to be the illusion
of sanity begins to basically come to
the surface when Batman effectively
prevents him from accessing the
Dionysian in order to basically go
through and heal himself from his
injuries and maintain his longevity but
in this moment of desperation the tables
are turned
Batman seems to be the insane one Batman
is one that doesn't care whether he
lives or dies he's ready to die with the
Joker the Joker struggling to live The
Joker struggling to come out on top and
that's why this is so cool is because
it's a reversal of what we're used to in
the last few moments of what seems to be
their lives Batman and the Joker switch
places
suddenly Batman's the guy who doesn't
care anymore and the Joker's the one
that cares about living so again it's
kind of a cool little bit of a scenario
here but and what appears to be the
death of Bruce Wayne we pick up
basically two weeks later with you know
the bat-signal basically being broadcast
out in terms of just memoriam of sorts
the bat family of course seeming to
grieve Alfred definitely not being able
to get over this but it's also this idea
that even Alfred and Julia have to come
to grips with the fact that it was
inevitable that Batman was going to die
it was inevitable that Bruce Wayne was
going to die as Batman because his life
is tragedy that's what his life is and
it was never going to be anything other
than that because he was almost like a
martyr it was almost like this idea of
I'll fight as best I can
I'll stem off against the bad guys as
best I can but if I die maybe it'll
inspire other people to take up my
mantle and become even better
superheroes then I was it was really
just kind of setting himself up for the
purpose of keeping the Batman legacy and
keeping the Batman mantle continuously
going on but with that being said guys
we are gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come let's explain make sure you ask the
sub button to become part of the rob4 if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like again we can really just
kind of drop it off here we know
Batman's alive so we know that he
survived the experience but we can go
ahead and kind of drop it off here wrap
up our new 52 Batman explanation series
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments in terms of scott Snyder's
Batman run I think it's absolutely
stellar and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]